MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome back
to 8.20, special relativity.
In this section, we want to
discuss Lorentz transformation.
Or, in other words, given
an event observed by Bob,
we want to express that
event as observed by Alice.
We want to find the translation
between the observations
in Bob's reference
frames to the observation
in Alice's reference frames.
We have already done
this for the classic case
as Galilean transformation.
Now, we want to do
this in the framework
of special relativity.
In order to simplify
the discussion,
we don't worry about the
y- and z-component here.
Those dimensions
can be neglected
if we assume that the relative
motion between the two
reference frames
only in x-direction.
We also know from the
previous discussion
that you can use the
invariant interval.
ct squared minus x squared
is the same observed in Bob's
and in Alice's reference frame.
We'll make use of this fact.
And, lastly, we can assume
that this transformation
has to be linear.
Why?
Because we transform something
like a measurement of distance
into a measurement of distance.
It has to be linear.
If not, we find something
like a length squared
or the same for time.
And we might end
up on time squared
if we don't do this correctly.
All right, so we can write
this down as a linear equation,
which is a multiplication of
a matrix with a vector, ct, x,
into a vector, ct [? x ?]
[? prime, ?] x prime.
OK, so the goal
here now is to find
the parameters or the
coefficients of this matrix,
OK?
I invite you to stop the video
here and try to work it out.
It's an interesting exercise.
It tests your algebra knowledge.
There's not much
physics in here,
but it's still useful to go
along and try to work this out.
So the first thing
we want to do is
assume that the origins
coincide at t equals 0.
And then we can follow along
the trajectory of the origin
of S prime in the S frame.
So this is just ct, vt.
OK, great.
This already gives us a
constraint on the coefficients
a1,0 over a1,1, which is
equal to minus v/c, OK?
And then we can use
the invariant interval,
which is another constraint.
And we can use this to obtain
the set of equations here.
I will not read this for you.
And that's already
enough in order
to solve the set of equations.
So, if you do this
and follow along,
you find answers for
all four coefficients
given gamma and beta as
we defined them before.
This then simplifies to
our Lorentz transformation.
So the only thing we did here
is we simplified a little bit.
We assumed that this is
a linear transformation.
We used the invariant
interval in order
to set the constraints.
And we find Lorentz
transformation.
If I summarize this,
we find this matrix
here with coefficients gamma,
minus gamma beta, minus gamma
beta, and gamma.
Great.
Or, if you want,
you can write this
as an equation for the
spatial component and the time
component.
So does this make sense?
There's always a chance
that we make a mistake
in this kind of calculation.
So we want to make sure that
the answers we developed
in previous sections
actually are reflected
by this transformation.
So let's go one by one.
The first thing we
can do is check units.
If we do that, we see that
this first equation here
is of unit meter, and then we
can analyze the second part
of the equation.
OK, so gamma is unitless.
x is of unit meter.
And then we have beta ct.
Beta is unitless.
c is meter per second times
second, also of unit meter.
So this checks out.
The second equation
is very similar.
c times t is of unit meter.
Meter per second times
second is of unit meter.
Gamma is unitless.
Beta is unitless.
And then we have an x,
unit [? meter, ?] plus ct,
c, meter per second
times second, also meter.
So this checks out.
So this is great.
At least we find that we
have a linear transformation
by design, and the
units work out.
So now we can see,
what happens now
if we use this for
velocities which
are much, much smaller
than the speed of light?
In this case, gamma is equal to
0, and beta is very close to 0.
If we put this in our
equations, you find x prime
is equal x minus vt.
And t prime is equal to t.
OK, this checks out because this
is our Galilean transformation.
So, for systems
which move relative
with very low difference
in velocities,
we can use Galilean
transformation
as an approximation of
Lorentz transformation.
OK, at a third part, now we
can investigate a little bit
further.
For example, what happens
now to a distance,
just a measure of
distance or a measure
of length, which
we obtain by making
this measurement simultaneously
at t2 equal to t2?
We find delta x prime is
equal to gamma delta x.
All right, that's
length contraction.
If we do the same
thing for delta t,
for doing the
measurement of time
at x equals-- x2 equals
x1, we find time dilation.
All right, this is
exactly what we expect.
And then we can look
at two events which
happen at the same
time in frame S
and see what
happens to the time,
as measured in system S prime.
Delta t prime is equal
to gamma delta t.
Well, in this example,
we set this to 0.
And then we have the
second term, which is minus
beta over c gamma delta x.
So we find that, while this
event happened simultaneously
in our frame S1--
or in S, it does not
happen simultaneously
in our frame S prime.
There's an extra
term, which is not 0
unless you actually measure
at the very same point,
l is equal to 0.
So this is the relativity
of simultaneity.
Again, this checks out.
And I think we're good with
our Lorentz transformation.